we are beyond where I've ever been
before
I don't know where we're going spade
doors Spade doors yes okay I can kill
that guy now - she's pretty cool
probably do that
oh wait wasn't one of these a spade door
know you've unlocked another door with a
key card though
oh yeah the one upstairs no I wasn't
upstairs Oh
oh yeah up these stairs right here sorry
I haven't been in it I'll do that now I
think I'll do that now
glug glug glug oh no what is it because
if it's people I'd rather have these
we shall find out show yourself
huh
no there's a lot oh no oh no there's
like 50 of them oh my god
shotgun not sorry no I did I did because
then you killed that first guy so he's
dead
but I shot a bunch of other people if
you want to go shock on him you can no I
need that for the liquor do I need
anything in there you don't really need
to kill the liquor if you could just
keep dodging I mean you'll eventually do
I need to go in here I'm not telling you
I actually don't think I killed any of
them
no boy should try something close shot
gun if you aim up and time it right you
could shoot like six dudes heads off
you just gotta aim up I'm out of bullets
you might be better off reloading that
save or dying and then go from that
saving just with a shotgun I don't know
how to do that this is the worst is the
worst beginning that ever began I barely
began and I'm in trouble I suck
I didn't know that there would be 40
dudes in there where are you going I'm
gonna reload to save is it can I reload
from here no really no ah just die
just go die yeah it's up to you whether
you want to but yeah yeah I want to die
only recommend it I'm not pleased with
my performance I can do better I just
didn't want to like have to kill myself
I figured I could just load no I need
you think they need they demand blood
give the people what they want is this
what you want
is this it you want to see me die how
that me zombie scum eat him feast on his
flesh yeah you did oh he's dead now yeah
yo they're eating my belly
that guy's eating that others but you
see it his head was in his but it was
clipping does what those okay so I
actually want this one yeah
the world of survival-horror they really
quite actually should heart named the
genre survival horror interesting
alright I got a good feeling about this
one it's a shotgun all the way got it I
just feel like every time I pass the
liquor it's gonna take a swipe at me
that's my concern
do you can have a concern about that I
can't
get up get up try to get closer
what that's right no you made it oh no
it's just like ideally you go for the
Hedgehog closer
no now pull out your handgun like don't
worry about that anymore
I just don't think this was thought
through oh I see blood
look at me looking at him oh there could
be stuff up here I hope it's bullets was
that did you hear that I definitely
heard it
oh no I'm full right off the main hall
you'll be fine
nothing is wrong that's weird
everything will be fine just climb
inside me Leon
what holy [ __ ]
what we're really close to what to this
day this game took place September 28th
for two days behind Oh how freaky would
that have been if we play this two days
ago I did play this game two days ago
that's weird wait a second
No
what no I'm out of like I'm out of
bullets
I actually don't know what to do like
like I'm in so much [ __ ] come in that
was close I don't think that guy's dead
but I think I could smash his head
I didn't Dodger I'm sorry there's no
blood
yes go stop her having a bad time
a red plant you full but yeah maybe
there's a thing in here that'll be great
you saw the Spade key on you yeah yeah
no I can't carry anything this is the
worst this was poorly planned you're
doing a bad job Mike I'm trying to guide
you les look what's happening as well go
check it out at least
why all I had to do is not carry these
rubies yeah well I didn't think you'd go
this way you're the worst oh my god I
hate it just go back to the liquor
hallway there's a spade key door right
in there the liquor hallway what's that
that's a door a club okay
damn this is like talking the same thing
not like that I mind I'm just saying
like how much a sword shield yeah I'm
the shield key just does one thing gets
into the Attic so you could fight yo
huyn that snake I don't see how this
could possibly top the first one like
sharks snake spiders like that game was
unreal it had all of the fears like I
just don't see what this one could have
this one I'm making that up funds like
South Carolina luring people in though
no wait where am I I didn't realize I
just went into a new place should I go
in there you can always come back here
if you want to you're not helping me at
all and I just don't appreciate it
ghost the East Wing so many wings all
right so let's drop off some [ __ ]
right yeah I'm a right sure yeah
all right so first things first let's
drop some rubies off mmm no bring those
now I need them now you do yeah no I
don't even know where you need them to
drop that off
you could still dodge the liquor I'd say
the way the liquor it's in the next
hallway well wait I'm going past the
liquor yeah there's a spade key door in
its hallway there's this other wing that
I was just in I wouldn't I'm just saying
when you get a key you want to try to
start like using all the doors possible
to get rid of it I just feel like
there's um there's unfinished business
here you'll go back there I don't want
to get hit by him but I feel like I'm
gonna get hit by now go just go to this
door tried to lick me I think I got hit
now okay well he did hit me
to third
see for
I'd like to copy these bullets
nice
I am taller than most people
crankshaft getting the hang of it I
don't think you totally don't need the
read Jules yet I hate you can't reload
if you want them how do I get that
crankshaft oh I see I got it all right
yeah
she's feeling it she can sense the ways
of this game now the game is making
itself known to her we both like I came
to terms with it the second yeah I'll
take the crank the square shape Leone
looks so different that photo out there
yeah oh yeah he's a freaking redhead in
the cut scene but in this in here - yeah
he's like more attractive that's like a
good-looking version it was like burnin
like brown hair that's his facebook
profile and then this is like what he
looks like in reality he's a he's
definitely not honest he's vain anything
else no what I need him you said
yourself they're really limited sure but
I'm saying okay but you could come back
here no no just take it I don't care I
don't give a [ __ ]
honestly like if it wasn't for the
rubies I tried to get rid of we would be
in this mess so
I am angry this is all this all comes
down to the rubies
don't be mad it's mad at me
you missed it herb because you wanted
the ink ribbons I don't need no herb
also I think there's a box in here stop
damn it
oh wait that's the breathing room
there's nothing in there I'm afraid you
know goats I just say boxing huh the
dark room I made one note cuz I wanted
to join in on your song was that one
note enough for you feeling
okay
so
get rid of these rebounds get rid of
these right chef take it
crank I should probably call it crank
not shaft crank shaft I think we all
know what I mean we're all in agreement
it's a nice normal door it's not like a
creepy mansion door
yeah input as much TLC into the to the
door noises did they not really good
she's so focused on climbing those
stairs one two three
was it this one
it was this one I think I killed
everything in here gosh just like a
little creaky noises I hate it so this
is the one there you go wow it had one
door too
I don't remember the second on the first
one was the liquor hallway with the
crank dumb
you just didn't over done nope can I
throw a grenade or something I think you
can just hug that what now you're gonna
[ __ ] him up I don't want to I actually
don't have aah what are you gonna do
can I hit them with a crank I don't know
I gotta
you just gotta kill him oh did I waste a
bullet yeah
the cappuccinos are out I'm leaving I'm
going away guys
you don't mind me I'm just going you
just [ __ ] your birth why
so much because it doesn't know I didn't
know that no I just playing on nothing
to do but shoot
not even a me at them anymore [ __ ] I
can't see oh my god I'm gonna [ __ ]
die okay well okay here once one grabs
you and you push them into the others
[ __ ] get out of there it's fine he's
dead now when you push this dude and the
others to get out of there give yourself
some space give a hurt you have a herb
this wait wait don't use that yes wait
poorly yeah that went very poorly get
wait give yourself space
reloading for [ __ ] totally yeah what
like only [ __ ] don't have infinite
ammo guns this went so bad did I'm out
oh yeah things and I'm hurt I hope
they're all dead I do I investigate or
what sure I think you're good stay that
way
nothing thought there would be something
in there you know oh my god I hope
there's bullets in this library this is
it puzzle did you figure it out I did
I could go in that door I hope this is a
good you are not helping me at all tell
me more
no I actually don't think I can I'm out
of bullets like I'm in a lot of trouble
in the first one you told me which is
Ami's like a Duke
they're a lot more zombies in this game
all right so it's got the four
bookshelves there is
one on the first blue and orange then a
blue is skipped
then it's orange blue orange blue and
then orange is skipped and then it's
blue art so it's to skip two to skip two
I would think you're making it more
complicated than it needs to be and I
totally understand because the colors
but just make sure it's like a big gap
between the first in this and the last
you know what I will Oh
heaping injured
oh I see
wait yeah okay sorry I got it
all right yeah this one also needs to be
moved right
pretty sure dang it right I know
correct mm-hmm
so blue orange no I did it yep you know
I'm a genius I didn't realize that I
beat it or Stanley Kubrick
will you take the bishop plug
what's a bishop plug I think I should
still be able to go upstairs right
wasn't there more upstairs there was a
door up there it's a really skinny
staircase
it's just a scary staircase for one okay
so police station the library there's
this did you chose double doors yet
though it's down there yeah yeah that's
where although Dumbo's remember they
were there not yet I did there was a
bunch of zombies in there
a dead end great
all right
a useless hallway
crankshaft square hole still coming in a
crankshaft which confuses me what do you
think it should be called crank what's
wrong what's wrong with the shower over
crankshaft it is what it is I feel like
our generation has the problem with the
word shaft because we're terrible like
we're the only generation with our minds
in the gutter
we're the only ones that made that
connection for that word yeah but baby
boomers have their own innuendo like
what I was gardening yesterday
it's like oh oh I know what you meant
mrs. Thompson mm-hmm
you old bag god damn it I don't like
that my brains on the same way like it
looks like a switch Porsche me another
gear oh can I use this plug try it and
the game you have forfeited you're safe
the gun must die what iron plate seems
to have been made meat recently moved
all right so I need 8-year got it
upppppp
all right so gear go up to that quick
you read that yet
I thought I did it said nothing pretty
it says it's broken
is there anything else don't think so
okay all right get in places got a
bishop plug got a plug well yeah there's
nothing else in here so I could go to
that other wing I think probably the
next thing to do yeah I'm pretty sure
you didn't go through those double doors
I did there's a shits on his ah bees in
there remind me I don't have enough
bullets and I'm injured I don't want to
die I haven't saved in a really long
time where am I going
tell me where to go
yeah just go up here and dodge the guy
up there which guy shoot him and then
get by him
no if I shoot it there you go down lower
that shortcut this is an emergency
push it back to the typewriter now can
the zombies use ladders no great you go
save now if you want now that I feel
safe I'm okay I don't have ribbons on
you no is there anything else over here
yes quite a lot should I do that first
sure
I who could have seen this coming
I should save I don't feel good about
what I just accomplished no I can't I
let her down the right or the left come
toward the railing descend the ladder
holy I thought that I don't have it you
know all right I should save right
you're not to go past the liquor to get
through there save box but yes really no
that's not true
you keep forgetting about the save box
oh you're totally right sorry turn
towards the liquor get to them nearest
say bucks you do want to go back up the
Lariat a chance though I mean am i
abusing how many saves I have say V dis
key things I have you got the shortcut
that's it that's good progress oh [ __ ] I
see sorry this is not like a wagon herb
as well okay this is not like it was in
the first game no dude I've seen a lot
of [ __ ] like I'm really not healed at
all yeah I would roll this though for
now it's fine like this feels way more
dangerous than the first one
I think in terms of difficulty well
you're also on a harder difficulty to
begin with know if I'm Leon okay I feel
much better so I'll put this ribbon back
and then you think I should keep going
in that precinct let me see your
inventory yeah you could just call it
the latter unless you want so you're
already halfway there oh yeah go
upstairs yeah I'm just gonna put it away
because if I get a herb I don't want to
be like oh I'm almost full like let's
just get rid of it because I'm here it's
really not that far okay do I need my
gems don't lie to me yeah you could take
em
the gems
I'm like damn you're low on ammo
so [ __ ] low why why are you bringing
that up to me
because I don't want you to be
optimistic
ascend it's hard to know where the
zombies are like it's hard to Juke if
you don't know the depth yeah does these
next two dates at pause but where are
they like this is where I got in [ __ ]
creek because I didn't know see Kobe
Bryant who uses the low semicircle you
got Diggity damn click Clank using my
crank shaft that is
what you did not have to go downstairs
for the save box damn it now we know I
feel like maybe it's early in the game
I'm not got enough but I feel like
you're doing well on your own pick that
up
just type rate I accidentally moved one
of the stone statues of the second floor
when I leaned against it when the chief
found out about it he was furious I
swear the guy nearly bit my head off
screaming never touched statue again
hundreds of thousands of dollars and I
was being a mystery where the things
special things or where he's getting the
money from
what he's like what he's art though yeah
like who are we to decide it beep it
nobody ever appreciated most of our
artists and our day don't pick up this
thing actually yeah there's a boxer in
this room he can pick up those incra
pins rebonds did you call them ribbon
ribbon ribbon sir
it's done
the deal has been made god I hope
there's no zombies in here because I'm
freaking out of bullets and I haven't
saved
no what means you could dodge him too
who could have predicted zombies
resident weevil
no I've been tried the store first
I've been harmed by crows in the past
how did i unlock it small key head
outside can I have this wait let me see
I wouldn't worry about it yet I love
that noise in background you think it's
wind or zombies they're both
yeah they do a good job of coming
convincing lets you know no I I needed
the weight handgun bullets please no I'm
out of ammo
try dodging you know if you get the
right camera I can't afford to get hit
again not to our jury
yeah it's June ideally you won't use
those he could same for later but still
cuz you want to combine them with red
O's mm-hmm I just wanted to reset should
I go in there or in the room go in there
and we're in there in the room yes this
room mm-hmm
dip diary just cat-and-mouse and around
the table oh god there's three of them
and they both decided to go different
ways don't run toward um no you're fine
there's damnit
no no I really don't want to die yeah
this is the worst I'm in so much [ __ ]
now I like your back here you swing you
know where you are now
no you're back on the ground floor near
that door he tried but there's too many
people this is where those five zombies
were or six or whatever
I am it it lo healthier what am i doing
go back to Indore
no yeah this is usually go in the office
the chief's office nice nice
alright you're no closer to the office
but you are but hurry though he's if
there isn't
come back out lure them all to the same
side of table just don't panic
so I get them all the you know like get
in the line oh I see
take some patience but oh the hair bye
yeah where's the fourth one he's such a
dick if he went this way
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] nice nice there
you go hold on hold on let him I'll
catch up
give me some time that office
oh yeah you got your good I don't think
I have a lot of time in here safe two to
three series [ __ ] what was it - - told
you forget - two three six maybe I
[ __ ] it up I'm full that's it doesn't
take up space
alright can I leave you check the test
you on hmm they're behind it no I'm out
of time what their own desk just run
some behind ya
man i Scott Afton a no you're good hmm
yeah come around this way there's
zombies in here no you need a heart you
think yeah
this is the worst I have been royally
screwed
what should I do je1 sure that wasn't
worth it yes actually no don't even take
that one
don't take that you would have had to
eat that one anyway the red jewel is
terrible advice on my part you think
you'd you're going closer done dude cuz
I like what that way oh right the crows
Cross forgot about that
what
oh [ __ ] lady nice but I don't have a
hand I don't have an H gun sprint you
told me not to spring around crows
since they're pecking me to death I love
that music shits gone down over here
you need my patch should I see if this
is no don't walk into the fire
No
getting it come at me
[ __ ] oh no Paul a telephone pole
was her undoing they're zombies never
saw it coming which hand got around next
to it as well don't pick up those the
red jewels are terrible advice on my
part - them your honestly I thought we'd
get there fast yeah you've been so
unhealthy you're the one playing the
game you would have picked up so many
look at that new Depot poster we
wouldn't seen that if I tell you come so
many new toes get that crank that valve
oh right for the water pressure you know
what I will take that all right wait now
this door yeah sure story looks good I
like the story try da jammin getting
around I can't
first door ever that they came through
you can try going around the dodging in
there
what do you mean like dodging them in
there to go through that door they came
through oh okay I'll try
I feel better about juking now yeah seem
it's getting a little bit more
comfortable the problem is is
understanding the depth like it's hard
to understand how much space I have
mm-hmm I really don't want to die oh god
there's no space there's no space yeah
there's there's no space where just do
it come towards you just kind of beat
him but he he's coming the wrong way
back into this other corner nice you
went right into her fault door nice you
should just get out of here I actually
hate ya you just there is a difference
between not helping me and you're fine
though you have to bad person
it's like straight up some [ __ ]
here's some caution you fun Oh give it
you will make me go back into danger
well you were fine I thought you'd be
able to dodge it you said yourself
you're confident
pee on the copter
see I think that's a generational seam
what's a generational thing did I do all
that for bullets no there's more
just not here though like you can leave
this area but back from what you came
you'll see you'll see you'll see I don't
understand you shovel dad these crows
first crap all right where am I going
where's the liquor I feel like I'm
worried I actually don't think I can
take another hit no really kill him
really yes we're dodging you don't dare
go after you coming go that was it down
that hole so this would have been
covered in flames if you didn't I just
go through that door quickly [ __ ] go
through that door
right there to the right it should be
coming up on I don't have anything oh my
god you'd be fine you're fine
there's a lot of blood on the floor look
at me blood is just a shadow look at me
run all right now you can get rid of
those goddamn red jewels on either those
either side of that a what a woman
relief hole about the size of a fist
damage her with the rubies oh my god I
look like such trash danger I'm fine
just shoot this dude in the hole you got
my family do we have you take that [ __ ]
do we
I'm not gonna live like you're obstinate
you're like about the visib is killing
me
got a lot of plugs here you gotta get
back to save bucks really badly you're
not that far from one so don't despair
no I need to heal like super bad this
next hallway
just [ __ ] kill the student I if he's
outside if he's like really close to me
he's gonna kill me
no just [ __ ] you don't have any other
choice just throw some bullets into him
this is the worst I don't like it why
can't I pick up my gun you go don't have
it lit I was close I'm really glad I
practiced yep
start shooting him as soon as you get
through oh my god hi die I'm a [ __ ]
mad don't die come on Mary I don't know
where he is he's coming to shoot him
it's easy yeah
nope fine you're fine you got a lot of
space and a lot of bullets he's dead
wait that one out though what would that
sucks can I die from an ankle injury
probably yeah
come on inch up a little bit just like
CVD change the camera angle to see him I
think he looks dead all right it's got
blood get the [ __ ] out of here
aren't there zombies in the place I'm at
I'm going live also did you know if I
find a plant I can't pick it up because
I'm [ __ ] filled with plugs you're
gonna save it right now could be the
episode yeah that's good you're actually
good shape you got the next no I'm not I
work so dead you know we're a fuckload
of herbs are and you know these have a
safe room right now
yeah yeah get the cover for now in the
clubs no I keep the hang-up I don't have
any handguns handgun the pistol what
have you thought they were the whole
time I thought they were special bullets
now yeah get the Rolex for now I can
reconvene that take anything except
anything ribbons all right
not good at this no I don't want to talk
about it I'm so close to death
look at my hobbled ass carcass trying
it's hybrid so I know we've been doing
only one a week but that's because I
went on vacation at the time you guys
are watching this I'm actually in
Disneyworld
but coming back when I come back we're
gonna do way more of these to a week as
as per usual mm-hmm so thank you guys
for watching please don't forget to Like
and subscribe because it helps us to do
these yeah and maybe maybe Mary won't
[ __ ] up and what it sure you too to just
support me I'll try sure next time
penultimate